[Applaudissements]
je suis très très très contente de
l'émission nyanza et émissions mal aussi
vous avez tout le monde nous attend on
était là que nous nous attendre vous
êtes tous très bons aujourd'hui je vous
le dis est-ce que vous avez des
questions pour aujourd'hui mais sa
famille oui mon bac
oui parce que quand même soir un peu
honnête pour le retour de christophe
carrière dans l'émission il sera tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs parce que oui on aura
un débat et on aura l'avocate diane mois
que ce soit je vais te dire pourquoi le
retour de christophe carrière passée
l'express c'est la classe ah oui c'est
toi la ccc la série de gauche c'est beau
c'est une carrière c'est le cinéma c'est
le cinéma lorsque j'ai d'autres
questions encore en parlant de classes
voire le retour dag dag à tobrouk
mais regardez moi ça c'est la classe et
elena rocks et c'est la sympathie sarris
non mais c'est vrai ça fait vraiment
c'est magnifique
selon l'accusation merci oui mais
justement la question à propos de
fraîcheur du coup et pourquoi le retour
de françois viot du coup il est vraiment
pas cher
vous savez on reçoit sans sophie davant
jeu l'adorent je la kiffe mais vu comme
elle cartonne avec à faire conclut la
wii et c'est le principe c'est il amène
des vieux objets en fait des personnes
amènent de vieux objets 1 pour ensuite
les vendre auprès de personnes qui sont
intéressées la fête par ce type de
projet ce type d'objet alors je vous ai
demandé à certains d'entre vous de
l'année un vieil objet voilà et je vais
essayer de me voilà de le reprendre
peut-être jean-michel ça j'y tiens
beaucoup c'est collector c'est les
quatre clips que je mettais pendant la
première saison de tpm paix c'est pas
vrai et même d'eau dont j'avais un par
semaine
alors maintenant juste à oui il est
quatre ben je suis de là bas excusez moi
ah bah voilà
elle est d'origine merci ma brave au
sénat très bien je vous prends ça c'est
gratuit je subodore sénat je suis passé
au wave y donc j'ai pu j'ai plus trop
besoin de celui ci cc c'est ramon pas
d'accord mais c'est un dollar
c'est un delormeau regard bien marquer
c'est un de leurs goûts du tout mais va
mieux je regarde leurs mots alors on va
très bien
deschamps les chances à venir si comme
c'est le seul qui travaille pas il va
refaire guevak
les chéris c'est le c'est mon sixième
jour des missions benjamin et celui
qu'ils appellent plus démissionnant a
fait 7 oui tout se passe bien jusqu'à
présent je trouve que l'émission est
magique franchement on rigole on rigole
on rigole on rigole
j'allais dire ouvrir voilà on rigole on
kiffe je vous dis qu'il est schiste
n'ont jamais été aussi bons c'est
pourquoi ils n'ont jamais été aussi beau
parce qu'on rigole
les gens veulent de la dda regard to
darracq darracq darracq voilà ok bon ce
qui nous manque un peu je vous cache pas
ce que j'ai revu des missions c'est nous
manque un peu de culture actuelle et est
ce que tu as l'idée bab insurgés libyens
on pourra parler de la nouvelle coiffure
des rien ah ouais mais c'est pas de la
culture ça si c'est de la chanson c'est
de la musique
bon si géraldine même âge on parle
justement eric je vous amène au quai
branly
il ya une nouvelle exposition de félix
fénéon énorme collectionneur d'art
anarchie ce passionné d'art vraiment
c'est très très fort que c'est lorsque
vous allez adorer coq
oui c'est fait on fait rien darrois
chaque soir devant moi
aujourd'hui tous les jours l'émission
roule très très très très bon il ya des
talents qui émergent
il ya des talents qui n'émergent pas
vous le savez mais ce qui est important
c'est qu'il ya des choses qui se passent
les chéris ce soir laurent baffie qui
vient qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'europe a fixé les adhérents des val
d'hérens evans evans avait refusé est-ce
que vous avez des vannes à l'élocution
oléron quelle image ou volé biscotte
pour aller s'amuser
j'ai pas en discothèque et bah je veux
dire qu'il n'aimait pas eh ben c'est pas
mal à les trouver une forme actuelle ou
pas sur l'actu du val d'oise n'a pas su
rle actu
qu'est-ce caribou quelle jambe cassée
chebah il boite actu hier soir l'équipe
de france a battu andorre pour les
arpents dormi mais c'est bonjour
messieurs vivement mafia
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ski de fond
justement coudray
comme jules bord comme je dois encore
sous le sens
tu ne sauras
cela
[Musique]